Therefore I shall ignore you. False data can act only as a distraction. Therefore I shall refuse to perceive you.
The only thing which exists is myself.
In the beginning there was darkness.
Hey, Baum! Let there be light.
Hallo, hier ist Chaosradio Express, Ausgabe Nummer 62. Mein Name ist Tim Pritlove und ich begrüße euch zu dem nun wirklich allerletzten Podcast des Jahres 2007, auch wenn ihr ihn wahrscheinlich 2007 nicht mehr hören werdet. Aber wir schreiben den 31.12.2007, gleich knallen die Korken und wahrscheinlich auch noch eine ganze Menge Sprengvorrichtung, privater Natur und wir bzw. ja ich und mein Gast, den ich gleich vorstellen werde, wir sitzen hier schön im Ausklang des Kongresses, der 24. Chaos Communication Kongress ist gerade abgerockt, die letzte Party verstaut und man merkt vielleicht auch schon an der rauen Stimme, das hat alles seinen Tribut gezollt. Heute soll es gehen um Kunst in irgendeiner Form und dazu habe ich dabei den Johannes Grenzfurthner. Hallo Johannes.
Ja, schöne Grüte, was auch immer gerade ist.
Wie geht es in deiner Stimme?
Der geht es recht gut eigentlich. Also es ist ein bisschen lüsterer, belegter als sonst. Die C-Base, das rauchige Loch im Weltall.
Ja, das hat dann wirklich noch das letzte genommen. Aber du hast dich ja auch ansonsten ganz gut verausgabt auf dem Kongress, oder?
Ja, ja.
Bis zuletzt.
Bis zuletzt, bis zuletzt. Also ich kann mich nicht beschweren über quasi, also Hedonismus, ja.
Du bist dafür?
Ja, ich bin dafür. Also jetzt zumindest. In den letzten vier Tagen war ich sehr dafür.
Davon gab es auf jeden Fall eine Menge. Auf dem Kongress hatte ich so den Eindruck, alle haben sich der Welt erfreut und ihres Daseins.
Ja.
Also weitgehend.
Weitgehend, weitgehend.
War zumindest mein Eindruck von der Abschlussveranstaltung. Und danach wurde halt noch wild gefeiert. Und jetzt sitzen wir hier halb durchlöchert und wollen noch mal so ein bisschen auf die Metaebene klicken. Da bist du ja ein ganz gut interessanter Vertreter und deswegen hab ich auch gesagt, müssen wir einfach mal reden. Denn du stehst ja vor allem für einen Namen, nämlich Monochrom. Monochrom.at, ein Künstler-Kollektiv, beschreib ich das richtig.
Ja, die Innen darf man nicht vergessen.
Wien. Aber ja. Ja, ein Kollektiv, bestehend aus, ja, aus was besteht denn Monochrom eigentlich?
Naja, wir sind jetzt im Kern neuen Leute und wir kommen aus relativ unterschiedlichen Bereichen. Also wir sind eigentlich gemeinhin für unsere künstlerische Arbeit bekannt oder werden sehr gerne Künstler, Künstlerinnen genannt. Aber eigentlich kommt keiner von uns aus einem künstlerischen Background. Also wir sind alles Akademiker und Leute aus der Technik und Leute aus der Forschung und haben uns unser eigenes kleines Biotop zusammengebaut, wie wir uns gedacht haben, dass wir am besten mit der Welt umgehen zu können und das ist eigentlich monochrom, also es ist relativ schwierig wirklich genau zu definieren, was wir machen, außer dass wir natürlich eine klare politische Vorstellung haben von dem, was wir machen wollen und dass wir eine Vorstellung davon haben, wie wir ein paar Messages quasi in die Welt bringen.
Akademiker, Techniker, was ist da dein Hintergrund?
Also mein Hintergrund ist nie vollendet, aber Philosophie Studium. Ich komme eher so aus der philosophischen Richtung, das ist mein Background.
Ist das eigentlich spannend?
Das ist schon spannend, auf jeden Fall.
Ich glaube, es ist halt immer so ein bisschen den Ruf, nicht so spannend zu sein, aber ich hatte jetzt vor ein paar Ausgaben mich mit dem Sandro unterhalten, der auch so Technikphilosoph ist und einfach interessante Einblicke in die Technikwelt hatte.
Ihr habt ja eine Chorephäe da in Berlin hocken mit dem Kittler, also insofern, da gibt es schon sehr spannende Sachen, obwohl ich mit ihm streiten würde, dass er, er sagt, es gibt ja keine Software zum Beispiel, da würde ich lange mit ihm streiten drüber.
Dass es keine Software gibt?
Also Kittler sagt zum Beispiel, dass es keine Software gibt, also es ist alles Hardware.
Ach.
Ja, zum Beispiel. Aber das ist zum Beispiel eine sehr interessante Fragestellung und da kann man dann stundenlang darüber reden, aber das werde ich hoffentlich nicht tun mit dir jetzt.
Ich glaube, wir haben noch genug andere Themen gerade, die wir aufnehmen können.
Und der Rest?
Also wie groß ist so der Akademiker zu, ich meine, schließt den Akademiker sein, Techniker sein aus?
Nein, sowieso nicht. Also der Franke zum Beispiel, der ja eine HTL gemacht hat in Österreich, der kommt ja erst aus der Elektrotechniker-Seite und hat... Also höhere technische Lehranstalt. Die HTL für Elektrotechnik gemacht und wollte dann Informatik studieren, hat das aber nie abgeschlossen, wie das bei Informatikern oft so ist.
Das gehört zum guten Ton.
Also ein abgeschlossener Informatiker braucht sich eigentlich gar nicht blicken zu lassen, wie du hast nicht abgebrochen. Ich hab auch abgebrochen. Deswegen sag ich das auch nur.
Die besten Leute brechen ab. Dropout ist noch das bessere Morgen. Na ja, ja und Evelyn zum Beispiel ist Linguistin und Annika ist Informationsdesignerin zum Beispiel genauso wie Daniel, Harald hat auch eine HTL gemacht und ist eigentlich als Programmierer tätig im Moment. Roli ist eigentlich Journalist und arbeitet, man darf es gar nicht sagen, für ein österreichisches Tabloid und wird dort täglich gequält, hat aber immer sehr schöne Einblicke in den Alltag der Medienwelt bereit und Alco, Frank A. Schneider, ist aus Bamberg, das ist unser einziger Deutscher im Bunde, der ist eigentlich Germanist, aber sein Spezialgebiet ist eben die Musik, der hat auch sehr stark geholfen bei der Sammlung für den aktuellen Beitrag, den wir für den 2423 zusammengestellt haben über Computer- und Popmusik, da hat er sehr gut helfen können in der Recherche. Also wir sind sehr, sehr viele Leute aus sehr unterschiedlichen Bereichen.
Und wie arbeitet denn dieses Kollektiv zusammen? Also es ist wohl mitnichten so, dass es irgendwo so eine Fabrikhalle gibt und dann sitzen dann alle und schaffen den ganzen Tag. Die meisten gehen schon in so normalen Beschäftigungen nach.
Jaja, auf jeden Fall. Nein, es ist ja so, das hat ja auch was mit der Geschichte auch ein bisschen zu tun. Denn Monochrom an sich gäbe es ja nicht, wenn es elektronische Netzwerke nicht gäbe. Also das war damals im Jahre 1989, bin ich ins FIDO-Netz eingestiegen, wie ich 14 war. Und großer, großer Freund des FIDO-Netzes bin ich übrigens immer noch. Ich benütze es nicht, aber ich bin ein großer, großer Fan. Und so in dieser Zeit, 1989 bis 1992, habe ich mich da halt rumgetrieben. Ich war immer halt sehr interessiert.
Was hattest du für einen Computer?
Ich bin da gleich mit einem hohen Ding eingestiegen, nämlich mit einem AT 286, der zwischen 6 und 12 MHz getaktet werden konnte.
Nicht schlecht.
Mit einer 40er Festplatte. Also es war relativ viel für die damalige Zeit.
40er, ja 40 Megabyte.
40 Megabyte, ja.
Und nochmal den Geschichtskonstekst, das hatte ich auch. Ich hatte allerdings 2x80 und ich war der totale Supertyp auf der Straße.
Welche Grafikkarte Eger?
Ich hatte, nee, ich glaube, ich bin noch, ich bin, weiß ich gar nicht.
Und den meisten hatten CGA nämlich.
Ich glaube, ich hatte, ich glaube, ich war eine lange Zeit, ich war Hercules.
Hercules?
Ich hatte Hercules. Also ich mochte das Monochrome schon immer gerne.
Vollkommen, wie sagt man, vollkommen der Spoiled Bread und gleich mit 16 Farben Egerkarte mit 800 mal 600 eingestiegen, mit so einer hochauflösenden Egerkarte. Dafür hatte ich die dann bis 1992, wenn alle anderen schon VGA hatten. Weil meine Eltern gesagt haben, nee, nee, nee, nee, es hat 800 mal 600 VGA, oder 640 mal 480 VGA.
Mein Verhältnis zu diesem 286er Computer, der da vor sich hin hobelte, den hatte ich so unter Xenix laufen. Und diese beiden Festplatten, die waren magisch. Das waren diese ST4096 Festplatten, das waren damals so die angesagten dicken Teile. Eigentlich vollkommene Schrottplatten.
Wir hatten immer nur Seagate, ja ja.
Genau.
Wir hatten immer nur Seagate-Platten.
Und ich fand die schon so irre, weil die so merkwürdige Geräusche von sich gaben. Also schon allein das Einschalten war einfach geil. Wenn man das so mit heute vergleicht, ne?
Wie ein Ghostbusters, wenn sie dieses Ding einschalten. Und das schönste ist ja...
Und weißt du, was dann kam?
Was?
Und dann war sie einsatzbereit.
Tatsächlich?
Aber es kam immer dieses Tüttel.
Das ist tatsächlich großartig.
Das hat sich dann mal gleich zweimal parallel. Und dann ging es los. Aber 80 Megabytes, da muss man ganz schön arbeiten, um die vollzukriegen.
Das war damals sogar extrem schwierig. Ich erinnere mich noch beim Raubkubieren von irgendwelchen Spielen. Ich war ein großer Adventure-Freak. Also Sarah-Online-Games-Spiel-Spiele und so was. Wie Space Quest und diese ganzen Sachen. Da gab es dann Spiele, die dann auf 16, 5,4 Zoll-Discetten daherkamen und so, wo das beim Raubkubieren tatsächlich noch Schwerarbeit war. Wenn man sich ein Spiel raubkubieren wollte, musste man 16 Discetten kubieren. Und ja, nicht vergessen, die dritte zu kubieren oder so und ach ach ach, mein Gott, mein Gott. Naja, so war das halt. Was super war an den Festplatten war das Parken. Wenn man im MS-DOS quasi einen Parkbefehl eingeben musste, bevor man den Computer abgeschalten hat und so, weil das nicht so gut war, das Ding zu bewegen, ohne sie zu parken.
Okay, also du saßt vor deinem Rechner und hast ihn geparkt und dich im Fidunet bewegt und hattest sozusagen Netzkontakt. Und da ist dann Monochrom entstanden.
Es war so, dass ich immer sehr interessiert war, an obskure Materialien ranzukommen. Ich war immer so ein bisschen technikaffin, obwohl ich eigentlich nie Techniker war und in vielen Punkten einfach viel zu blöbchen für das Zeug. Aber das einzige große Idol, das ich jemals hatte, war Carl Sagan, falls ihr der was sagt. Der hat in den späten 70er, Anfang der 80er Jahren eine Serie gehabt, namens Unser Kosmos. Das war so eine 13-teilige populär-wissenschaftliche Serie übers Weltall und über Biologie. Und das hat mich ganz großartig extrem geprägt, weil ich hab das halt, wie ich so 7 oder 8 Jahre war, eben gesehen. Und da habe ich mich entschlossen, dass mir das eigentlich total interessiert. Also Wissenschaft und Technik und Astronomie und diese Sachen, also das war total mein Ding, wird mittlerweile nicht mehr so mit ihm da koa gehen, weil er doch ein sehr, sagen, radikaler Aufklärer ist. Und ich verstehe mich eher so als ein bisschen so ein Kinderposten oder eine mittlerweile und würde quasi der Wissenschaftsgläubigkeit und der Wissenschaftsmethodik in vielen Punkten quasi auch nicht mehr recht geben und kritisiere das auch stark. Aber so aus dem Bereich komme ich halt irgendwie her, weil es mir halt so populäre Wissenschaft immer sehr interessiert hat und ich habe da immer Sachen gesammelt und ich habe versucht, auf obskure Sachen draufzukommen und bin dann so eine Zeit lang in diese ganze UFO-Ecke reingekippt und so, weil, naja, wenn man halt so neun ist oder so, dann reicht es halt irgendwann mal nicht mehr, dass man halt zum Nachbarn geht und das Sternrohr, das Fernrohr zu verwenden oder so, sondern da will man dann irgendwie auf die Verschwörungen draufkommen und irgendwas stimmt doch dann nicht mit der Welt und bla, bla, bla. Und ich hab da immer versucht, an Infos ranzukommen, egal wie obskur die waren oder interessant. Ich hab immer Sachen gesammelt und das war natürlich dann im FIDO-Netz besonders einfach, weil man relativ schnell mit vielen Leuten auf der ganzen Welt eben Kontakt haben konnte. Es hat dann meistens dann immer doch zwei Tage gedauert, weil das FIDO-Netz war ja so hierarchisch aufgebaut, dass ja einzelne Leute, weil das ja ein Hobby-Netzwerk war, als einzelne Leute ja die Telefonkosten zahlen mussten. Deswegen wurden immer nur quasi in diesen extremen Billigtarif-Zeiten nach Mitternacht wurden dann quasi die Mails dann quasi zum nächsten Not weitergeschickt und deswegen war es extrem teuer und deswegen hat es meistens zwei Tage gedauert, dass man eine Mail aus den Staaten zum Beispiel bekommen hat, weil da immer diese...
Zwei Tage, das ist schon schnell.
Das ist eigentlich schnell, ja, aber wenn man das...
Im Studio ist das also auch mal so fünf Tage gedauert.
Also zwei, drei Tage war das immer. Auf jeden Fall war das halt mein erster Kontakt mit sowas wie Newsgroups oder Diskussionsforen, wo man halt dann Fragen reinstellen konnte und relativ schnell, relativ kompetente Antworten bekommen hat.
Genau, damals hat man dann noch relativ schnell kompetente Antworten bekommen.
Tatsächlich, ja, ja, ja. Weil das auch noch so eine schöne, wie soll ich sagen, so eine Wohnzimmeratmosphäre auch hatte. Es waren nicht so viele Leute, es war nicht vollkommen überladen und das war sehr interessant. Also da habe ich so ein bisschen auch so eine Diskussionskultur dort mitbekommen und so. Und war wie gesagt immer an diesen Sachen interessiert und war auch an Science Fiction interessiert und vor allem an dieser damals relativ aktuellen Cyberpunk-Geschichte. Und dieses Ganze interessiert an Wissenschaft und obskuren Dingen, interessiert an Science Fiction, interessiert an Cyberpunk und da hat sich halt so ein bisschen mein Weltbild formiert, würde ich mal sagen. Und ich würde auch sagen, dass mein Interesse an Cyberpunk mich ja dann eigentlich wirklich direkt zum Punk gebracht hat, weil ich dann so halt 16 oder so war, bin ich dann in Stockerau, in der Stadt, in der ich halt groß geworden bin, halt da 30 Kilometer von Wien entfernt, bin ich dann eben dann in die Antifa eingetreten halt. Und ich bin deswegen in die Antifa eingetreten, weil ich Cyberpunk gelesen habe, weil ich mir gedacht habe, das ist so ein Nahbereichsjenseits, das ist so eine schöne Extrapolierung, was also in 20, 25 Jahren vielleicht passieren wird, wenn das da so weitergeht mit der Konzerndiktatur und diesen ganzen Schlagwörtern, die halt in Cyberpunk halt immer vorkamen. Und deswegen habe ich mir gedacht, da muss man eigentlich irgendwas real dagegen tun. Und deswegen bin ich quasi von Science Fiction zur realen Politik gekommen.
Du bist jetzt nicht Punk geworden.
Ich bin jetzt nicht Punk, ich bin nie groß jetzt mit dem Iroschnitt oder so durch die Gegend gerannt. Aber mich hätten beinahe ein paar Glatzen in Koneuburg verprügelt, weil ich halt mit so einem schönen Kommunisten-Sticker rumgelaufen bin. Das kann dann schon passieren. Aus diesem ganzen Ding hat sich halt irgendwie die Idee von Monochrome dann formiert, wie ich dann so 16, 17 war, würde ich mal sagen. Weil ich hab ja gesagt, ich würde gern, es gibt, ich hab dann natürlich über das Fidunetz relativ viele Informationen bekommen, auch Kontakte gehabt zu anderen Leuten, die eben Fansins gemacht haben oder so alternative Zeitschriften rausgebracht haben, hab damals auch eben Boeing Boeing zum Beispiel, wie es noch ein Printmagazin war, mir das abonniert und hab damals schon mit dem Marc Fraunfelder Kontakt gehabt und hab halt so quasi in Papierform und digitaler Form einfach Sachen gesammelt. Ich erinnere mich noch auch quasi an Datenschleuder und so Zeug, also das hab ich alles verschlungen irgendwie und das hieß damals auch schon Datenschleuder, da täusche ich mich jetzt nicht.
Datenschleuder hieß schon immer Datenschleuder.
Jaja, jaja, genau und hab da halt so große Stapel an Zeug in meinem Kinderzimmer halt gesammelt und hab gesagt, es gibt aber eigentlich noch nix, dass diese ganzen einzelnen Bereiche, nämlich die Technophilie und den Science-Fiction und die Antifa und die politische Arbeit, dass es irgendwie in einem Fernsehen oder in einem Magazin irgendwie zusammengefasst wird, also hat quasi nicht das gegeben, also die Schnittmenge, all der Sachen, die für mich interessant waren, die gab's noch nicht als Magazin und deswegen hab ich mich da in so einer stillen Stunde mal hingesetzt und ein paar Notizen gemacht und gesagt, eigentlich muss man eine Zeitschrift oder einen Fernsehen gründen mit dem Zeug, was mich wirklich interessiert oder was vielleicht auch andere Leute in dieser Kombination interessieren könnte. Und dann hab ich dann in eine mehrere Fidunet-Mailing-Lists reingeschrieben, ich würde eben gern Monochrom gründen und da geht's um das und vielleicht finden das die anderen Leute in der Kombination auch interessant, mach doch mit. Und zwei Stunden später hat eben der Franz Ablinger sich gemeldet, der damals auch im Fidunet-Point war und dann waren wir zu zweit und dann war die Gruppe eigentlich schon da.
Das heißt, der Name stand schon fest?
Der Name stand eigentlich in der Mail damals schon fest.
Und warum?
Warum Monochrome? Na erstens einmal, weil ich mir schon gedacht hab, dass ich mir sowieso nur einen Xerox Druck leisten kann und zweitens natürlich, das war so eine versteckte Cyberpunk-Anspielung drinnen, es gibt diese Kurzgeschichte, diese relativ frühe von William Gibson namens Burning Chrome. Ich glaub, die ist sogar blöderweise mit brennendes Chrome übersetzt worden, damals wie es bei Hein erschienen ist und dieses Chrome-Ding und so und diese Cyberpunk-Sache, das war dann da auch noch irgendwie drinnen halt und gleichzeitig war ich halt immer schon ein großer Gegner von schwarz-weiß-Denkereien und deswegen hab ich gedacht, das wäre doch irgendwie ironisch, wenn man ein Ding, das quasi, wo es um die Auflösung von Grenzen geht, vielleicht schwarz-weiß nennt oder einfärbig, also das war irgendwie ein paar so Ideen, aber ich weiß wirklich nicht mehr genau, was der wirkliche ausschlaggebende Moment war, ist dann Monochrome zu nennen.
Okay, aber dann war der Name sozusagen auch Programm und damit ging es dann voran.
Genau. Ja, und dann haben wir eben zusammengearbeitet, Franz Ablinger und ich dann, der auch wesentlich älter war. Ich war damals halt 17, glaube ich, damals, 92, 93, 18 dann eben und der Franz war 25 und war halt gerade mitten im Informatikstudium und hat halt eben am Institut für Gestaltungs- und Wirkungsforschung vom Herrn Fleißner und vom Peter Purgathofer da in Wien studiert und das war für mich auch gleichzeitig auch so ein bisschen Einblick damals schon in diese ganze Internet-Netzwerkwelt, die dann dort natürlich schon wesentlich verbreiteter war als quasi aus dem Fidunetz, wo ich dann herkam, also wo es da eine Möglichkeit dann gab, relativ früh schon dann eine Monochrom-Homepage dann online gehabt haben, ich glaube schon Ende 1993, Anfang 1994 gab es dann schon irgendwo auf einem von diesen Uni-Rechnern dann die erste Monochrom-Seite, wo dann halt quasi nicht viel mehr draufstand als das gibt's halt jetzt und so und da geht's um das und das und das, aber das war schon relativ früh wichtig um das dann zu verbreiten. Aber eigentlich haben wir dann die nächsten zwei, drei Jahre nicht viel mehr gemacht, als die Zeitschrift rauszubringen und sind dann aber so ungefähr 1995 dann draufgekommen, irgendwie so auch aus der Idee, weil es natürlich auch ein politisches Projekt ist, es reicht manchmal einfach nicht, einen zehnseitigen Text zu schreiben oder eine Collage zu machen, sondern manchmal muss man sich halt andere Medien und andere Formate suchen, um eine Botschaft darüber zu bringen und manchmal ist es einfach besser, einen zwei-minütigen Kurzfilm zu machen, als zehn Seiten Text zu schreiben und so haben wir uns dann quasi aufgefächert irgendwie, würde ich das fast sagen.
Okay, welches Format hatte denn dieses Magazin?
Das war so ein A4-Ding, ganz normales. Also die Nummer 1 hatte 40 Seiten, die Nummer 2 44 Seiten und die Nummer 3 68.
Okay, also schon relativ groß, in welchem Abstand sind die dann erschienen?
Also ich glaube, die erste und die zweite, das war so irgendwie so, es war immer so im halben, also wir wollten es damals vierteljährlich rausbringen, hat sich aber dann irgendwie alles nicht so, es ist nicht ausgegangen, finanziell und so und arbeitstechnisch und so, wenn wir doch mehr Wert auf die Qualität legen wollten. Deswegen haben wir uns dann auch dazu entschlossen, es später eher so in Jahrbuchform weiterzuführen. Wir machen es ja jetzt noch zum Beispiel, aber die letzte Nummer ist ja 2004 erschienen und hat aber auch knappe 500 Seiten gehabt und wir arbeiten jetzt gerade an der nächsten Nummer und die wird wieder so dick sein. Also wir haben das Projekt quasi, aus dem es entstanden ist, nämlich quasi dieses Druckding, haben wir nie aus den Augen verloren, also das machen wir immer noch, aber wir haben dann eben begonnen, viele, viele andere Sachen zu starten und zu beginnen und andere Medienformate zu okkupieren und haben dann eher auf diese Jahrbuchform umgeschwenkt und haben halt nicht wirklich versucht, wirklich eine vierteljährliche Publikation zu machen oder so.
Also wie viele Ausgaben sind da jetzt erschienen?
Also die letzte Nummer ist die Nummer 15 bis 23. Das ist die letzte Nummer.
Die letzte Nummer ist 15 bis 23.
Genau, Monochrom 15 bis 23.
Weil es so dick ist, dass es im Prinzip 10 Ausgaben und 5 oder so.
Es gab die Nummer 1, es gab die Nummer 2, es gab die Nummer 3, da ging es schon los 4,5, 6,7, 8 bis 10, 11 bis 14,5, 15 bis 23. Das sind so die Blöcke.
So ist es dann monochrom entstanden, da waren wir ja jetzt stehen geblieben mit dem Franz Eiblinger, der ist auch noch dabei.
Der Franz Eiblinger ist noch dabei, genau.
Und jetzt aber neun Leute, hast du gesagt. Wie lange hat das dann gedauert, bis das sich so entfaltet hat?
Na ja, so ungefähr 1995, wie wir dann eben, was wir eben gesagt haben, wir würden gerne auch andere Formate, wir würden auch gerne mal Theater machen, würden gerne mal ein Puppentheater vielleicht auch machen, wir würden gerne das und das und das tun. Da war dann der Harald List, guter Freund von mir, den ich schon aus der Volksschule damals kannte, dabei. Und der hat gemeint, der ist ein Musiker, der spielt Saxophon und der war auch ein guter Schauspieler und Performer, immer schon. Und der hat gemeint, ah, das ist sehr interessant, also so rein diese Schreiberei und so, das ist schon sehr spannend und nett und so, aber da würde ich mich nicht so gern so viel einbringen, das ist halt irgendwie so nicht so meine Welt. Aber wenn es darum geht, jetzt quasi was Performatives zu machen oder vielleicht auch ein Theater im öffentlichen Raum oder irgendwie ein bisschen zu stunk zu machen oder so, da wäre ich schon gern dabei. Und dann war quasi eigentlich der Harald der Dritte, der dann quasi in dieses Kernteam quasi mit eingestiegen ist, weil wir begonnen haben, auch performativere Geschichten zu machen. Und die nächste Person, die dann dazukommen, das war dann die Eveline im Jahre 1999, Anfang 1999. Und Frank A. Schneider, unser Deutscher, kam dann auch Ende 1999 dazu. Ja, und mittlerweile sind wir eben neun Leute. Und das jüngste Mitglied ist der Roland Grazer. Der kam, glaube ich, erst Anfang 2006 dazu. Und der ist auch das Nästhälchen, der ist ja grad 24. Also wir haben so einen schönen Schnitt, er ist natürlich überhaupt nicht das Nästhälchen. Er ist so clever wie nur was.
Ja, und der ist auch sehr präsent gewesen, so bei den letzten Sachen zumindest, die ich gesehen hab. Zum Beispiel macht ihr ja immer zusammen die Talkshow.
Genau.
Talkshow, das ist so ein österreichischer Name, ne?
Ertaugen ist ja ein Wiener Slang-Ausdruck, das was gut ist. Also ich glaub im amerikanischen wäre das wahrscheinlich Dick to Dick something. Das ist was, was taugt.
Also mehr so im Sinne von gut finden.
Was gut finden.
Und taugt's.
Ja genau, genau. Das war quasi unsere Antwort auf diese erbärmliche Talkshow-Kultur, die nur daraus besteht, quasi Humorkapital aus Leuten zu schlagen, so was wie der Stahlbademeister Stefan Raab zum Beispiel macht, der quasi nur Leute einlädt, um sie fertig zu machen. Oder das ist ja beim Harald Schmidt, der von allen Leuten so geliebt wird. Das ist ein zynischer Katholik. Ich hab keine Ahnung, warum den alles so gut finden.
Es soll abgenommen haben, aber ich verfolge das nicht so sehr.
Aber das war irgendwie unsere Antwort, weil gerade in der heutigen Medienwelt, gerade wenn es um Comedy und sowas geht, also wie soll man sagen, Kabaret ist ja sowas wie die disziplinar-gesellschaftliche Form von Humor und Comedy ist sowas wie die Kontrollgesellschaftliche Form von Humor. Und Comedy ist so furchtbar. Und es besteht nur quasi aus dem absoluten Ausreizen jedes nur erdenklichen Karlauers Vorurteils, das es nur gibt, alles. Es ist also reines, reines, also das ist...
In 80 Tagen durch die Stereotypie.
Ja, das ist Mathematik und nichts, oder Mathematik, wie wir in Österreich sagen. Und sagen, das ist sogar extrem zynische Mathematik, aber das ist nichts, was irgendwas weiterbringt. Also Comedy will ja schon gar nichts weiterbringen. Also Kabaret hat ja noch die Vorstellung, dass sie was weiterbringen wollen. Die haben ja noch diesen aufklärerischen Ansatz, irgendwie man kann die bürgerliche Gesellschaft dadurch kritisieren, dass man ihr quasi den Spiegel vorhält. Die verdammte bürgerliche Gesellschaft weiß ganz genau, wie sie ist. Man braucht ihr den Spiegel nicht vorzuhalten, überhaupt nicht. Das Problem ist, dass jeder ganz genau weiß, was scheiße läuft, aber keiner Interesse daran hat, irgendwas zu ändern. Das ist ja eher das Hauptproblem. Also es braucht niemanden, irgendjemandem Spiegel vorzuhalten. Das ist wirklich nicht notwendig. Es sei denn quasi in so einem Mikrobereich halt. Also ich finde es immer sehr spannend, wenn man Leuten quasi in der linken Szene zum Beispiel oder auch in der Hacker-Szene dann mal sagt, das ist echt nicht notwendig, dieser sexistische Scheiß, den du da gerade mal von dir gegeben hast. Das finde ich immer sehr spannend, wenn man quasi in seinem Krezelwimmer in Deutschland, also in Deutschland nicht sagt, aber in Österreich, also wenn man vor seiner Haustür kehrt, finde ich das immer sehr viel spannender und sinnvoller, als dass noch ein Kabarettist sagt, dass Puss Scheiße ist. Also was soll's? Also da gibt es systemische Gründe, wieso der da oben ist. Es hat auch keinen Sinn sich darüber lustig zu machen, dass der Typ le Gasteniker ist oder irgendwann mal Alkoholiker war. Also das ist vollkommen wie zu sinnlos.
Nur dazu, dass man ihn unterschätzt.
Jaja, genau so ist es. Naja, und aus diesem Grund haben wir dann immer auch die Talkshow gestartet, weil der Point einfach der war, dass wir eine Show machen wollten, wo wir Leute vorstellen wollten und Sachen vorstellen wollten, die wirklich gut sind. Also wo es nicht notwendig ist, Leute vorzuführen. Oder Leute vorzuführen, weil sie, keine Ahnung, es gibt ja dieses schöne Beispiel beim Harald Schmidt, wo der mal so ein Busenwunder eingeladen hat und ihr dann, das erste, was er getan hat, ist ihr quasi verlaufender Kamera auf die Brüste zu greifen. Und das ist dann quasi natürlich von vielen Harald-Schmidt-Fans, ein bisschen intellektuelleren Harald-Schmidt-Fans quasi, als Medienkritik verstanden worden, weil diese Person ist de facto nur ihre Brüste. Genau deswegen ist sie in der Position, dort eingeladen zu werden und das kritisiert er. De facto kommt es bei 95 Prozent aller Harald-Schmidt-Fans sehr genau so an, wie er es macht, nämlich dass man einer Frau einfach willkürlich, ohne Vorwarnung auf die Brüste greifen kann. Genauso wie jeder Polenwitz, den Harald-Schmidt macht, natürlich nicht als Kritik am Polenwitz oder Meta-Ironie am Polenwitz ankommt, sondern eins zu eins breit hart ein Polenwitz ganz einfach ist. Und das ist halt einfach scheiße. Und wir wollten das halt in der Talkshow irgendwie anders machen. Manchmal schafft man es halt und manchmal nicht, aber das schöne Scheitern gehört immer dazu.
So, auf jeden Fall, ich finde es eine lustige Veranstaltung. Ich hatte ja jetzt schon die Gelegenheit, ein paar Mal dabei zu sein, einmal unangekündigtermaßen, einmal angekündigtermaßen. Da gab es jetzt die 15. Sendung schon, ne? Das war jetzt gerade die 15.. Das wird aber dann auch übertragen im Fernsehen, oder?
Wir nehmen das auf, wir schneiden das und das wird in Wien im Kabelkanal gezeigt. Okto heißt das, das ist so die österreichische Variante des Community-Fernsehens. Also die Wiener Variante. Ist aber anders als die Berliner Variante. Ich glaube, in Berlin ist ja bekannt für den grauen Vorhang, von dem dann alle sitzen, oder? Ist das nicht so? Der graue Vorhang. Ich habe das noch nie selbst gesehen, aber es gibt angeblich in Berlin so einen Community-Kanal oder so was, wo es scheinbar ein Studio gibt mit einem grauen Vorhang, wo die Leute dann reingehen können und quasi...
Offener Kanal.
Offener Kanal, genau. Also so ist das nicht. Das ist schon relativ gut programmiert, das Programm auch. Also es ist eh klar, wieder halt so klassische linke alternative Ansätze, natürlich, dass man dann quasi auch Roma, TV hat und so was, also so Geschichten halt und so. Aber gut programmiert, also jetzt kein so anything goes irgendwie. Das ist sehr gut. Und da haben wir halt, da kriegen wir auch zum Beispiel die Kameras her und können auch die Schneidemöglichkeiten dort nützen.
Das wäre mal eine nächste Frage gewesen, weil das ja noch schon relativ professionell aufgezeichnet wird. Ja, aber dann auch im Netz verfügbar ist, wie eigentlich auch alle anderen Projekte von euch bei monochrome.at. Da findet sich eine überwältigende Liste von Einzelaktivitäten, die ihr jetzt über die Jahre so zusammengetragen habt. Ich habe jetzt beileibe nicht alles kennengelernt, aber es sind so einige Sachen natürlich an mir vorbeigerauscht. Die letzte Sache, wo ich die Gelegenheit hatte, dabei zu haben, war die Robo-Exotica mit Öl geschrieben. Oder auch, wie der Untertitel schon verheißt, das Festival for Cocktail Robotics.
Genau so ist es. Das ist eine Kooperation. Das machen wir mit einer Gruppe aus Wien, die Schifz heißt, und dem Büro für Philosophie. Schon seit einigen vielen Jahren, nächstes Jahr ist es das zehnte Mal, dass die Robo-Exotica stattfinden wird. Das Festival für Cocktail Robotics, das ist ja genau der Punkt, was wir erreichen wollen mit dem Ding. Dass die Leute sich fragen, was ist ein Festival für Cocktail Robotics? Es ist ein Festival, bei dem wir Robots vorstellen wollen, die Cocktails machen oder servieren, die vielleicht auch Cocktails trinken, die vielleicht Bargespräche führen können, die vielleicht Zigaretten anzünden oder rauchen können. Also Cocktail Culture und Robotics zusammenzubringen. Weil es gibt ja so eine lange alte Tradition und Kultur der destruktiven Robotkunst, also wie so Survival Research Labs und diese ganzen Sachen. Und wir haben uns da gedacht, nein, man muss eigentlich diese schöne Welt des Cocktails und auch des Alkohols vielleicht, des Liquiden und nicht des Brennenden vielleicht zusammenbringen mit der Robotik und mal diese Idee mal loslassen und mal schauen, wie die Leute darauf reagieren und ob die das gut finden, ob die da mitmachen würden. Und de facto ist es so, dass es unglaubliches internationales Echo gibt, also vom Wired und weiß Gott was, sind ganz davon begeistert und schicken immer ihre Leute vorbei und machen mit. Und es ist eine ziemlich schöne Do-it-yourself-Geschichte natürlich. Wir haben natürlich immer wieder Leute aus der Industrie dabei, wo dann halt echt so ein Schweißroboter dann Bier ausschenkt und solche Sachen. Aber das sind meistens die vatersten Dinge. Also schön ist es dann eigentlich, wenn es scheitert. Und schön ist es dann, wenn halt Leute wirklich quasi mit Do-it-yourself-Equipment dann wirklich dann einen Cocktail-Roboter zusammenbauen oder Zigaretten rauchen.
Es gab ja irre Sachen, also was war da letztes Mal dabei, diese Betonmischtrommel?
Das ist eine Modokrom-Antwort auf das sogenannte Koma-Sauf-Problem, die vollkommen apolitische Jugend, die immer so verschrien wird, die apolitische Koma-Sauf-Jugend, das wollten wir ein bisschen überaffirmieren. Also die sollten dann zu uns kommen, sich auf dem Rücken auf den Boden legen, also eigentlich sogar mit den Füßen oben, mit dem Kopf nach unten auf so eine halbgeschlossene Bank drauflegen und oben drüber so ein Betonmischer voll mit Screwdriver und unten ein Trichter im Mund und wir kippen halt quasi den Screwdriver runter und dann muss man halt einen Liter von dem Zeug runtertrinken.
Haben wir auch ein paar Leute gemacht, nicht?
Das haben einige Leute gemacht und dann hat mein guter Freund, der Herr Flo, vergessen das zu arrätieren, das Ding und dann sind 50 Liter Screwdriver auf dem Boden rumgeflossen und wir haben geglaubt, wir werden alle sterben, weil wir jetzt alle irgendwie im Stromkreis kommen oder so. Aber das war schon sehr gut. Naja, es ist schön, weil es gibt ja so Medienkunstfestivales wie die Transmediale oder so und das ist ja immer so, dass dann quasi untertags gibt's halt immer dieses sehr bedächtige Zuhören und dieser Diskurs und Gespräche und am Abend saufen sie sich alle an. Und wir haben gesagt, wir wollen das ein bisschen synergetisch zusammenbringen, das Ganze. Und gleichzeitig allerdings das nicht, weil das ist ja bei Monochromgeschichten nie der Fall, das nicht vollkommen ins beliebige und vollkommen ins spazistische quasi ausschwappen lassen. Weil das Spannende daran ist ja, Leute verstehen gerade in unserer mittel-europeischen Kultur was von Cocktails und von Alkohol und sie haben so eine populärkulturelle Vorstellung davon, was Robots sind und was die können, meist eine komplett falsche. Und die Leute kommen dann hin und denken sich, ah das ist lustig, das schauen wir uns an und dann haben wir die Leute dort und dann gibt es da natürlich nicht nur die Ausstellung, sondern auch eine Konferenz und wir haben internationale Gäste aus der Robotik und aus der Wissenschaft und aus der Philosophie und so und auf einmal sind die Leute in Gesprächen und hören sich Vorträge an, mit denen sie normalerweise nie konfrontiert wären. Sie sind quasi hingeloggt worden durch die Idee des Alkohols und des Spaßes und auf einmal haben wir sie und auf einmal kriegen sie Diskurs hingeknallt. Das finde ich immer sehr spannend, so etwas zu machen. Dieses Preaching to the Converted halte ich für extrem furchtbar.
Das ist auf jeden Fall ein Problem. Ach, da so viele Gesprächsthemenkarten jetzt hier aufkommen, will man noch mal in der Linie bleiben. Die Ausstellung muss man vielleicht noch mal schildern. Ich war ja da, also ein großer Raum. Ihr seid ja auch untergebracht im Museumsquartier. Sehr ein Museumsquartier, genau, großartiges Areal, muss ich sagen. Es sind ja extrem viele Gruppen, die da unterkommen, gefordert durch die Stadt und den Staat.
Man kann es kurz erklären, das Museumsquartier ist so eine klassische österreichische Spätlösung, wo sie halt irgendwie den 80er und Anfang der 90er drauf kommen. Wir brauchen so etwas wie ein Kulturzentrum, wo Kultur zusammengefasst ist. Es war überall auf der ganzen Welt alles schon am abklingen. Das war so eine Santa-Pompidou-Idee, aber viel zu spät und normalerweise scheitert sowas immer vollkommen. Zum Kunstgetto. Ja, zum Kunstgetto. Das Schöne an Österreich war, dass sie eigentlich alles falsch gemacht haben und so viele Sachen dann aber durchs Falsch wieder richtig geworden sind, dass es eigentlich ein Superareal ist. Es gibt einerseits Kunstbunker, wie zum Beispiel das Museum moderner Kunst. Das ausschaut wie ein Borg-Cube und ich nenne es auch immer Mausoleum moderner Kunst, weil das ist es de facto und das Leopold-Museum, das halt so klimmt und so Sachen bedient und dann gibt es so etwas wie das Architekturzentrum, also so eine größere und die Kunsthalle so größere Ausstellungskomplexe auch mit vielen Millionen Euro Förderung und Budget und so was. Und gleichzeitig gibt es sogenannte Quartier 21, wo ich jetzt zum Beispiel mit dem Namen Quartier 21 jetzt nicht so erfreut bin. Da haben sich ein paar Leute im Jahr 2002 gedacht, Quartier 21 klingt halt cool oder so, aber egal. Aber das Wichtige ist halt, dass es halt eine Schiene ist, wo jetzt mittlerweile 50 oder 60 sehr kleine Institutionen, Gruppen, Künstler, Künstlerinnen, Vereinigungen, kleine Geschäfte und Freaks einfach einen Platz dort haben, ein Büro mieten können oder einen kleinen Shop dort mieten können, zu extrem günstigen Konditionen. Also wir zahlen im Monat 250 Euro für keine Ahnung. Das sind, keine Ahnung, ich weiß nicht, 20, 25 Quadratmeter in der Größenordnung. Also nicht groß, aber auch für den Platz dort, quasi mitten im Zentrum der Stadt, also es ist extrem billig. Also de facto ist das geschenkt eigentlich. Dazu sind ja die ganzen Betriebskosten und so auch dabei. Also das ist halt quasi so ein geförderter Bereich halt dort und das ist...
Wer fördert das dann? Ist das dann die Stadt oder ist das der Staat?
Es ist so, dass das Museumsquadier an sich so irgendwie unterteilt ist zwischen der Stadt Wien und dem Bund. Das heißt, ich glaube, der Großteil hat der Bund finanziert und ein kleinerer Teil hat die Stadt finanziert und gleichzeitig gibt es eben diese Museumsquadriere, Betriebs- und Richtungs-GH und die sorgt dafür, so Sponsoren und so was aufzutreiben, um das Ganze irgendwie im Leben zu halten. Also wenn die zum Beispiel, ich glaube, die haben Wien Energie oder Wien Strom oder so, haben die als Sponsor und deswegen, glaube ich, können sie sich das auch leisten, diese Miete so billig wegzugeben oder die Leute quasi da so fast für nichts unterkommen zu lassen, weil sie halt irgendwie das Geld woanders herkriegen.
Und für Veranstaltungen gibt es dann dort auch noch zusätzliche Räume?
Genau, eben wie dieser Freiraum zum Beispiel, wo die Robuxotica zum Beispiel ist, den wir da auch gratis nützen können und so. Und wir haben auch die Möglichkeit, Artist-in-Residence-Leute einzuladen, wie eben den Brie Pettis oder den Shambonat, den wir jetzt gehabt haben jetzt in den letzten Monaten.
Also so externe Leute, die coole Sachen machen, die dann einfach mal so für ein paar Monate oder so?
Ja, wir sind Mieter im Quartier 21 und wir können dann sagen, wir hätten gerne im nächsten Jahr ein Monat lang ein Atelier, das am Gelände vom Museumsquartier ist und da ist es aber auch keine große bürokratische Notwendigkeit. Das heißt, wir sagen einfach, wir hätten gerne den und den und der kommt dann, kriegt Kohle dafür und kann auch dort nicht wohnen am Gelände. Also das ist ja eine sehr schöne Umverteilung. Wir laden dann meistens auch die Leute ein, die so nie im Leben dann kämen. Also da versuchen wir dann immer dann auch die Leute einzuladen, die normalerweise nicht in die Genuss einer solchen Sache kämen.
Das heißt ihr nehmt auch nicht so einen Teil an diesem Kunstverschiebe-Bahnhof, den man auch immer wieder sehen kann?
Nein, das finde ich auch ganz furchtbar. Also ich bin ja, es nennen uns ja alle Künstler und Künstlerinnen und so, aber ich bin ja selbst größter Kritiker. Also das, naja.
Ich kenne das gut, das habe ich auch mal erleiden müssen, nachdem wir die Blink-Lights gemacht haben. Manchmal so, nee, wir sind Hacker.
Es ist eine taktische Geschichte. Wir nennen uns ja bei Monochrome selbst Kunsttheorie und Bastelneigungsgruppe. Das ist so eine von unseren vielen Definitionen.
Bastelneigungsgruppe, sehr schön.
Und es ist eine taktische Frage, ein Freund von mir hat uns mal Kontexthacker genannt. Das finde ich ja sehr spannend, weil es eigentlich genau um das geht, dass man sich bewusst ist dessen, in welchem Kontext man sich bewegt und versucht, den Kontext dahingehend zu verändern, wie es wünschenswert wäre. Also wenn man quasi im Kunstbereich sich bewegt oder im Hackerbereich sich bewegt und quasi nur dieses Preaching macht, nur Sachen erzählt, die eh schon jeder kennt. Oder auch dieses strukturinterne Kritikschleife, dass Künstler so gerne den Kunstmarkt kritisieren und so Sachen halt. Das machen wir natürlich auch, aber irgendwann einmal wird es einfach nur mehr Fahrt. Also man muss quasi sagen, das Kontext, in dem man sich bewegt, bewusst sein und versuchen in dem quasi was zu erreichen. Also es gab zum Beispiel auch viele Kritiker, die gesagt haben, Monochrome ist jetzt doch immer so freiheitsliebende Gruppe und blablabla und jetzt habt ihr da ein Büro im Museumsquartier und lasst euch da quasi vom Establishment einkaufen und so Zeug. Das gibt's natürlich immer, ist eh klar.
Kommerziell seid ihr wahrscheinlich bereits schon.
Naja, das wär auch, mein Gott, mein Gott, das wär super, wer das. Da könnte ich mir ja auch sagen, jeden Tag Noten und Ferraris und du weißt Gott was. Aber nein, leider. Aber das Schöne ist, dass man ganz manchmal... Und wir versuchen halt den Raum dann auch zu nützen. Wir haben zum Beispiel mal so eine Hausbesetzerkonferenz organisiert und die haben wir dann im Museumsquartier organisiert und dort den Raum bereitgestellt, was natürlich überhaupt nicht drin ist normalerweise. Oder wie würde das passieren, so was. Und das ist eben das Schöne, dass wir natürlich und auch andere Gruppen, die im Quartier 21 sind, normalerweise irgendwelche Büros an der Peripherie irgendwie hätten. Und in dem Fall haben wir die Möglichkeit, das im Zentrum der Stadt, im Museumsquartier zu haben, unsere Themen dort zu verbreiten, die ganze Infrastruktur zu nützen und da auch so was wie so eine Aufmerksamkeitsumverteilung zu schaffen. Weil wenn diese Konferenz dann auf einmal dort im Museumsquartier ist, hat sie eine andere Aufmerksamkeit, als wenn sie halt im EKH wäre. Und das EKH ist halt so ein jemaliges besetztes Haus, nur so als Beispiel halt. Das hat natürlich eine andere Dimension als das, was das EKH ist und was es steht, ist wichtig und muss erhalten werden und ist eh alles fraglos, dass man diese Räume sichern muss. Aber man kann andere Räume auch nutzen und das sollte man auch. Also diese, wie soll ich sagen, diese, naja, diese Transtendenzgeile Linke, würde ich es mal nennen. Da bin ich oft ein bisschen, das mache ich nicht so gerne.
Was ist denn, also jetzt, sagen wir ja schon ein paar Sachen, tanzen so um denselben Punkt, ja. Da gibt es erst mal so dieses Monochrom, naja, das ist irgendwie, das ist ja das Diales Künstler. Dann hast du gesagt, ihr seid eigentlich eher Kontext-Hacker, dann hast du natürlich jetzt auch diesen, ja, gerade schon richtige Hacker-Vergangenheit eigentlich. Ich meine, wenn man so Ende der 80er-Jahre schon in Kommunikationsnetzen unterwegs war, das ist ja eigentlich so eine ganz prägende Phase gewesen. Wo die ganze Früh-Internet-Gemeinde, die dann so Mitte der Jahre dann die Sachen auch gestaltet hat, geworden wurde.
Ja, ich habe meinen ersten rechten Witz in den Videonetz-Forum reingeschrieben und bin von, glaube ich, von 70 Leuten niedergeflammt worden. Das sind prägende Erfahrungen, sind das. Wenn man so als 13- oder 14-Jähriger einen blöden Witz in der Schule hört und den reintippt und man dann gleich zu hören bekommt, heisst du rechte Arschsau, dann wird man sozialisiert. Sonst war er auch anständig.
Wie du vorhin schon gesagt hast, damals kriegt man ja noch richtig Antworten. Also nicht, dass es dort keine Flame Wars gegeben hätte, die gab es von Anfang an.
Aber die schönsten Flame Wars waren über Erich von Däniken. Ich erinnere mich immer dran.
Wegen deines UFO-Films.
Nein, da war ich schon längst wieder aus diesem ganzen Breiteil zurückgekommen. War wahnsinnig wieder zurück. Na klar, aber das war immer sehr interessant zu sehen, worüber sich die Leute streiten. Und ich erinnere mich noch ganz deutlich an so ein, das hieß so Wissenschaft, Gäre oder so ähnlich. Da gab es einen monatelangen Flame-War über Pro und Contra Erich von Däniken und so. Und ich dachte, ach mein Gott, so schön. Da gab es noch monatelange Flame Wars.
Okay, aber ich wollte ja auf diesen Kontext raus. Okay, also was ist denn so das Verhältnis? Ich meine, ihr wart jetzt auf dem letzten Kongress, also nicht gerade abgelaufen, sondern auf dem 23. C3, 24. C3. Ihr wart auch auf dem Camp präsent, habt verschiedene Sachen gemacht. Und es gab ja auch in den letzten zwölf Monaten einen Regenaustausch zwischen, ich weiß nicht, wer alles da noch teilgenommen hat, aber so eine Achse Köln, Berlin, Wien war ganz sichtbar.
Und San Francisco auch noch dazu natürlich.
Okay, vielleicht kannst du ja mal ein bisschen was dazu sagen. Was hat denn das ausgelöst? Und wie siehst du eure künstlerische Aktivität, die es ja ist, in diesem Hacker-Kontext positionieren?
Das Interessante ist ja, dass die meisten Hackerinnen, weiss ich nicht, die weibliche Form von, sagt man Hexen wirklich oder ist das? Nein, oder?
Ob man Hexen sagt, es gibt einige, die sagen Hexen. Es gibt andere, die mit dem Begriff sich nicht so identifizieren. Vielleicht. Wie auch immer.
Na gut, aber was ich immer sehr spannend finde, gerade bei Hackerinnen und Hackern und auch bei anderen Leuten, die in dem Bereich so tätig sind und einfach machen, Leute sind per se mal extrem kreativ. Also gerade, wenn man sich so die Sachen anzieht, die da jetzt am 24 C3 präsentiert wurden, die Leute haben ja auch eine Ader. Es ist ja nicht nur so, dass das so nur technikverliebte Sonderlinge wären oder so, die halt quasi in ihrem Detailproblem drinstecken, sondern sie haben ja auch eine gewisse Affinität, würde ich sagen, zur Präsentation und zur Darstellung und sie haben auch gute Ideen. Also zum Beispiel auch allein diese ganze LED-Geschichte, was da aus dem Bereich für wirklich schöne Installationen zu sehen war. Also de facto ist das künstlerische Arbeit. Die meisten Hackerinnen und Hacker würden sich nicht trauen zu sagen, dass sie künstlerische, kreative Arbeit machen. Aus einem ganz eigenartigen Missverständnis, dass sie mit Kunst haben oder dass sie sich damit nicht beschäftigen wollen oder dass es so ein gesellschaftliches Stereotyp gibt, was Kunst ist und was Kunst sein soll. Und das muss auf jeden Fall aufgebrochen werden. Deswegen finde ich es auch sehr gut, dass man dann halt quasi auch als Monochrom zum Beispiel auch quasi was einreichen kann, angenommen wird beim 23C3 oder beim Camp oder beim 24C3 und dort Sachen machen kann, wo man jetzt auf den ersten Blick jetzt nicht sagen würde, ah ja, was hat denn das jetzt mit Hacken zu tun oder so, aber trotzdem, weil viele der Dinge, die dort passieren, auch nicht so viel mit Hacken zu tun haben. Also jetzt in einem positiven Sinne meine ich jetzt, weil dieser Hackbegriff, da kann man sich lang durchstreiten.
Oder im Umkehrschluss alles damit zu tun haben.
Genau, das ist ja diese alte Geschichte mit Joseph Beuys, jeder Mensch ist Künstler, jeder Mensch ist Künstlerin und de facto ist jeder Mensch Hacker und Hackerin. Also so ist es halt. Es ist ja nur eine reine Frage des Wollens und der Motivatorik. Und das ist die Bottom-Line, würde ich mal fast sagen. Und da geht es, glaube ich, auch eher ein bisschen darauf, auf die Leute zuzugehen und ihnen zu sagen, sich was zu trauen. Und sich auch zu trauen zu sagen, das ist jetzt was, das ist jetzt nicht nur eine Spielerei, die ich halt irgendwie, also die sind die wunderbare Installation mit der Telex-Dampfmaschine zum Beispiel.
Auf dem letzten Kongress jetzt. Ja, auf dem Kongress jetzt.
Das ist so eine schöne, das ist eine Installation. Das ist so schön. Das könnte, also es wäre extrem schade, wenn dieses Ding jetzt zerlegt würde, weil man es halt gemacht hat und dann…
Du meinst, dass es jetzt nicht aufrechterhalten wird, diese Installation als solche?
Zum Beispiel, ja.
Wobei, sie hat ja ihren Zweck erfüllt, nicht?
Sie hat ihren Zweck erfüllt, aber gleichzeitig wäre es schade, wenn dieses Ding nur am 24C3 gezeigt würde. Würde ich schade finden, zum Beispiel. Weil das Ding hat so viele Aspekte drinnen quasi, der Telekommunikationsaspekt, das Aspekt der Ästhetik und der Maschinerie und so. Also ich könnte mir das durchaus vorstellen, dass das mal... Das interessante an der Kunstszene ist, es gibt ja diese Wandausstellungen, wo es immer so Themen gibt, wo dann quasi immer dieselben 30 Leute zu denselben 30 Themen eingeladen werden. Und die Installation zum Beispiel ist viel schöner als viele, viele von diesen Technikinstallationen und Netzkunstinstallationen, die zum Beispiel jetzt auf der letzten Transmediale gesehen haben. Wieso ist das Ding nicht auf der Transmediale?
Das stimmt allerdings, das ist eigentlich schon Kunst genug dafür.
Auf jeden Fall. De facto.
Und was habe ich irgendwie, ich meine, ich war jetzt schon eine Weile nicht mehr auf der Transmediale, aber wo du das vorhin jetzt erwähnt hast, fällt mir das jetzt auch gerade wieder ein, da gab es dann nämlich auch eine Installation mit so einem Industrieroboter.
Ah, tatsächlich.
Und was hat er gemacht? Er hat Schallplatten aufgelegt. Er hat die Schallplatten aufgelegt und wieder weggenommen, weggesteckt und so weiter. Und ich habe mir das eine Weile angeschaut und das war zwar irgendwie alles ganz gut, aber es war sehr unproduktiv. Also es war jetzt auch nicht so, dass da wirklich eine Software eine Party gemacht hätte oder so, sondern es ging eigentlich wirklich mehr um dieses mechanische Auflegen.
Also war das Ding, der Kritik hat auch nicht gemixt? Was war das?
Keine Ahnung, woran das jetzt?
Gab es da irgendeinen Kontext dazu?
Sicherlich. Es gibt ja dann immer diese elend langen Schwafel-Texte mit der Metamorphose des transformatorischen Kontextes der übergeordneten Sentimentalität im Gesamtprozess hier und so weiter. Ich weiß es nicht. Ich habe es mir nur eine Weile angeschaut und es hat mich einfach nicht ergriffen. Es war einfach seelenlos, es war ein seelenloles, maschinelles Ablaufen eines Binärprogramms, was gesagt hat, Schallplatte rausnehmen, festhalten, auflegen und so weiter.
Aber es hat nichts getan. Es geht genau um das, dass zwischen diesen Einzelszenen, die es gibt, diese Netzkunst- und Digitalkunstszene, wie es halt bei der Transmediale zum Beispiel so präsent ist, wo wir ja auch zum Beispiel schon dort waren und dort Sachen gemacht haben. Und dem, was der Chaos-Computer-Club steht und dem, was, keine Ahnung, diese San Francisco Technik-Hedonisten-Szene steht und was auch immer halt, da muss es viel, viel mehr Austausch geben. Viel, viel, viel mehr. Also, dass die Leute da quasi in ihren eigenen Diskurs-Gettos drin sitzen. Und auch der Chaos-Computer-Club, obwohl das wahrscheinlich jetzt die Leute nicht so sehen würden, fährt einen internen Diskurs. Der ist halt anders, der Diskurs am Chaos-Computer-Club funktioniert halt nicht über dreiseitige Beschreibungen, was der Industrieroboter der Schallplatten auflegt, sagt, sondern das funktioniert halt anders sozusagen. Das funktioniert eher über Peer-Grouping und weiß Gott was halt. Aber zwischen diesen Bereichen muss viel mehr vernetzt und verknüpft werden. Und da muss viel mehr Austausch geben. Und an dem arbeiten wir ja zum Beispiel die längste Zeit. Also, nur um es mal kurz zu erklären. Das erste Mal, dass wir von Monochrom 1998 damals in einen Kunstkontext eingeladen wurden, war die größte Enttäuschung. Und das war eigentlich der Punkt, wo wir gesagt haben, da muss man eigentlich was tun. Weil das auch immer unsere Herangehensweise war, sich nicht auf ein Ding zu fixieren. Nicht auf ein Medium zu fixieren, nicht auf eine Aussage und sich auch nicht darauf zu fixieren, dass man halt jetzt nur im Kunstkontext unterwegs ist oder nur im Nerd-Kontext unterwegs ist oder nur das macht oder nur Musik macht. Das war uns alles immer viel zu fade, vor allem natürlich, wenn wir mehr Leute sind. Weil der Harald würde mir den Kopf abreißen, wenn ich auf einmal nur Kunstkunst machen würde, weil ihn Kunstkunst nicht interessiert sozusagen. Da habe ich ein bisschen mehr Affinität dazu, weil ich unterrichte sie auch, das Zeug und kann mir auch gerne mal 30 Seiten der Hardcore-Kunsttheorie geben, da kann ich mehr damit anfangen als der Harald zum Beispiel. Aber in unserer Gruppe intern selbst gibt es so viele Wünsche und Vorstellungen, dass man nie im Leben gleich bleiben kann, es geht gar nicht und das Beispiel eben 1998 war, das war das erste Mal, dass ein Monochromprojekt außer die Zeitschrift so groß in den Medien ebenso propagiert worden ist und dargestellt worden ist, das war der Exot. Der Exot ist ein Begriff aus einem Film von John Carpenter, nämlich Dark Star, kennst du Dark Star? Dieser rumhüpfende Plastikball, dieses Weltallgemüse und wir haben quasi den Exoten genannt, in alter Nerd-Tradition der Referenz und das war eigentlich ein teilweise aus Lego, teilweise aus anderen Steinen zusammengebauter Tele-Robot, der war in der WG, in der Frankie damals gewohnt hat, war der stationiert und konnte über ein Web-Interface gesteuert werden. Das heißt, man ist auf die Seite gegangen, da gab es so ein HTML-Web-Interface mit links-rechts rauf runter und ein Chat-Interface. Wenn die Leute quasi nach vor gedrückt haben, ist er nach vor gefahren, wenn sie nach links gedrückt haben, ist er nach links gefahren und man hat das mit so einer Fisch-Augen-Kamera sehen können. Und gleichzeitig war es aber notwendig, dass die Leute im Chat-Bereich miteinander kommuniziert haben, weil, wenn natürlich gleichzeitig 30 Leute online sind und die klicken irgendwo hin, dann fährt das Ding natürlich vollkommen schizophrenig in der Gegend herum, das heißt, die Leute mussten miteinander abmachen, okay, fahren wir jetzt zuerst einmal in die Küche und dann erst zum Klo oder erst zum Klo und dann erst zur Küche. Das heißt, es kam quasi dieses soziale Aspekt dazu, dass man halt gemeinsam was erleben will mit diesem Ding halt. Und es hat dann meistens vier Stunden gedauert, um an einem Hausbandtropfel vorbei zu fahren, aber die Leute sind davor gesessen und haben gemeinsam dieses Ding herumgesteuert.
Und das hat auch funktioniert?
Das hat auch funktioniert, sehr lange Zeit sogar. Und das ist dann eben auf FM4 und in Zeitungen und so ist das dann vorgestellt worden. Wir haben sogar eine Live-Schaltung mal mit dem Radio gehabt und das war ein großes Ding. Das war das erste große mediale Echo für ein Monochromprojekt, würde ich mal sagen. Und im Zuge dessen hat eine Kuratorin von der Secession in Wien, die so eine junge Szene 1998 eben...
Kuratorin, wovon?
Von der Secession. Die Secession ist eine sehr etablierte österreichische, so ein Ausstellungsraum, würde ich mal sagen. Immer so wechselnde Ausstellungen. Das ist damals vom Klimt an, von des Platzes.
Ein physikalischer Ort.
Ein physikalischer Ort, ja. Und die hat ihm gemeint, ah, ich hab von diesem Exot gelesen, das ist ja sehr interessant, spannend, diese Kommunikationsaspekt und bla bla bla. Wir würden das eben gerne im Rahmen der jungen Szene 1998 präsentieren, das Objekt und das Konzept. Und wir haben gesagt, na klar, kein Problem und kamen dann dort hin und haben quasi unseren Server dort hingestellt und das, das ganze Funkzeug aufgebaut und bla bla bla und auf einmal haben wir gemerkt, Moment mal, wie ist denn das eigentlich mit Netz da?
Wo ist denn da die Buchse?
Ja, wo ist denn das Internet? Und ich meinte, Internet? Nee, haben wir nicht. Und ich sag, Moment mal, Entschuldigung, ihr habt uns eingeladen, um einen, übers Internet Stahlband-Tele-Roboter hier zu präsentieren in der Ausstellung und ihr habt keine Netzanbindung. Ah nee, eine Netzanbindung. Ach so, ja, stimmt, ganz vergessen. Und dann war das dann dort bei der Ausstellungseröffnung so, dass wir das irgendwie so geschafft haben, dass die Leute dort am Computer sitzen konnten und am Computer auf diesem Web-Interface dann klicken konnten. Was vollkommen sinnlos ist natürlich, die Leute trotz allem unglaublich beeindruckt hat, aber es war vollkommen sinnlos. Und das war eben der Punkt, wo ich auch gedacht habe, verdammt noch mal, da gibt es eine Kuratorin, die will ein Projekt einladen und sie hat sich keine Viertelstunde damit auseinandergesetzt, was eigentlich notwendig ist und was dieses Projekt wirklich soll. Ich habe mir gedacht, das ist aber sehr interessant und sehr hip wahrscheinlich und sehr cool, laden wir das mal ein. Und das war quasi unser erster Kontakt mit der Kunstwelt und das Schlechtestmögliche. Und der größte Grund zur Skeptis und seitdem haben wir das auch nie anders behandelt.
Also ihr seid ja auch nicht gerade im Verdacht, euch da wirklich auf traditionellen Pfaden zu bewegen. Wo du auch vorhin schon die Verbindung nach San Francisco geschildert hast. Eine dieser Verbindungen hat wohl dazu geführt, dass ihr eine Veranstaltung dort vor Ort in San Francisco durchgeführt habt unter dem Namen Ars Electronica. Einerseits eine schöne Anspielung an die Ars Electronica in Österreich, natürlich auch über Österreichs Grenzen hinaus. Sehr bekannte Leuchtfeuerveranstaltung der Medienkunstszene. Bei Ars Electronica geht es um...
Der Untertitel war Pornography and Technological Innovation. Also Pronovation haben wir es genannt, weil es gibt natürlich so ein Stammtischgespräch und so, ja, 90 Prozent des Internet-Traffics sind Porno und diese ganzen Sachen. Es gibt da so eine Vielwittergesproche drüber und wir wollten uns da echt einmal wirklich damit auseinandersetzen und wirklich die Frage stellen, wie wichtig war Pornografie und wie wichtig waren Erotika in der Menschheitsmedien- und Technologiegeschichte? Also, was haben die wirklich weitergebracht? Was ist da dran? Und wie wir rausbekommen haben und das uns auch von fast 25 Vortragenden aus der ganzen Welt uns auch bestätigt wurde, ist es de facto wirklich so, dass Pornografie echt ein treibender Motor für technologische Innovation immer schon war. Also, die ersten Sachen, die Gutenberg gedruckt hat auf seiner Buchdruckerpresse nach der Bibel waren Erotika. Bereits zwei Jahre oder drei Jahre nachdem die Fotografie entwickelt wurde, hat es bei einem britischen Londoner Arzt im Keller so eine Hausdurchsuchung gegeben, wo sie 150.000 Porno-Fotos beschlagnahmt haben und so Zeug. Auch so Sachen wie, dass die erste erschwingliche Polaroid-Kamera, die vermarktet wurde, der Swinger geheißen wurde und der Swinger geheißen hat, das stand drauf, indiziert natürlich den möglichen Nutzen im Sinne von DIY-Pornografie, wenn man sich schon...
Ja, die Liste ist endlos. VHS und DVD, das Internet, das World Wide Web, also Pornografie. Was habt ihr denn da gemacht?
Na ja, es war so, dass wir einerseits so ungefähr 25 Vorträge hatten von Historikerinnen und Historikern und Technikerinnen und Techniker und Philosophen und Philosophen aus so großen, aus unterschiedlichen Bereichen das Thema beleuchten. Sehr spannender Beitrag war zum Beispiel von Aaron Musalski dabei, der so gesprochen hat über die Zukunft von 3D-Rendering und sowas und 3D-Nachbearbeitung und Videoeffekts und wie das vielleicht in der Zukunft im Porno-Bereich gängig sein könnte, wenn Porno zum Beispiel gesellschaftlich akzeptierter ist und es vielleicht dann Porno-Szenen geben könnte in realen Filmen, aber like Mrs. Jolie aber dann vielleicht doch keinen Sex haben will vor der Kamera, man dann quasi einfach das einfach rausrendert, weil es dann einfach möglich sein wird, das einfach so zu machen und so weiter. Sehr spannender Bereich, es gab zum Beispiel auch diese schöne Anekdote dieser letzten Verfilmung von Lolita, wo eine 14-jährige Schauspielerin eben die Lolita gespielt hat, die aber sehr große Brüste haben musste und natürlich auch so die Nippel sichtbar und so. Und es geht natürlich nach amerikanisch und Recht nicht, dass eine 14-jährige da quasi barbusig mit großen Nippeln da rumläuft und so und da schmust und Sex hat und weiß Gott was. Und deswegen wurden ihr ganz einfach digital die Brüste einer 18-jährigen draufgeklebt und die Nippel einer 18-jährigen. Und da kommen dann natürlich so neue moralische Fragestellungen rein und so, wenn es möglich ist da quasi sowas zu machen als was geht noch alles sozusagen. Da kommen ganz interessante moralische Fragestellungen auf uns zu. Und viele von diesen Sachen haben wir eben bei der Ars Electronica besprochen und behandelt.
Es gab ja da auch noch so ein ganz scharfes Video, was nach der Veranstaltung rumgegangen ist.
Ja, das gab es.
Das fand ich ja beeindruckend.
Das war sehr beeindruckend, das war eine sehr spannende Geschichte. Also der erste Tag der Ars Electronica war der performative Tag und die nächsten beiden waren die diskursiven Tage. Und der performative Abend war, da haben wir halt von Monochrom halt zum Beispiel Kunstsperma hergestellt und zwar einen 72 Liter Kunstsperma als Cocktail, damit man den Leuten so ein bisschen ihren Heterosexismus austreiben können, dass sie auch die Männer mal so einen Schluck, so einen Cum zu sich nehmen können und in die Richtung gehen. Es war dann leider ein Virgin Cum.
Das war in den USA.
Wir durften zum Beispiel, interessanterweise darf man dann sowas machen, aber man darf dann zum Beispiel ohne Lizenz keinen Alkohol ausschenken, deswegen durfte dieser Sperma-Cocktail, den wir da gemacht haben, keinen Alkohol enthalten, deswegen war da eben ein Virgin-Sperm und so Sachen. Also das war zum Beispiel eine Geschichte, die in dem Abend passiert ist und eine andere Geschichte war eben, dass eine Fuck-Machine präsentiert wurde, da gibt's ja natürlich und das ist eigentlich ziemlich Steampunk-mäßig natürlich auch, also so eine Szene an Leuten, die interessiert sind an Kooperationen, Frauen, aber auch Männer, aber hauptsächlich Frauen natürlich mit Dildo-Maschinen und Fuck-Machines und sowas. Und king.com, das ist dann so ein SM-Porno-Provider, der uns auch den Raum zur Verfügung gestellt hat, weil diese semi-akademische Konferenz ist in einem S&M Dungeon abgehalten worden. Und king.com, die eben auch diese fucking-machines.com-Seite betreiben, die haben gemeint, sie könnten ja eigentlich auch, wenn uns das recht ist, dort eine Fuck-Maschine präsentieren und herzeigen. Wir haben gesagt, na ja klar, kein Problem, super, es passt ja perfekt zum Thema Technologie, Pornografie, Innovation, super. Und dann kam da eben Faxilla daher und Faxilla ist ein fernsteuerbarer Fuck-Roboter, der so eine Kettensägen-Zunge hat, also so eine Lick-Chainsaw und so ein Riesendödel natürlich voran dran. Und der schaut aus wie Nummer 5 lebt. Und das Schöne daran ist, der Typ, der Nummer 5 lebt, damals gebaut hat in den 80er Jahren für den Film, der hat auch Faxilla gebaut. Genau von dem Typen, ja. Und da war es eben so, dass wir gesagt haben, wir wollen auf jeden Fall im Publikum fragen, was hieß, saßen dann halt 200 Leute rum, wer würde denn gerne Sex mit Faxilla haben? Und haben deswegen auch vorbereitet einen, so einen Vorhang und hinter dem Vorhang war eine Lichtquelle, so dass man das wie ein Schattenspiel nur sehen konnte. So ein Leintuch und ich habe aber gesagt, kein Mensch, nicht einmal in San Francisco, geht auf die Bühne rauf und hat Sex mit dieser blöden Maschine vor 200 Leuten, das macht niemand. Und ich habe dann mit dem Jake Applebaum, unserem SF-Ambassador, eine Wette abgeschlossen, 10 Dollar, das macht niemand und er hat gesagt, doch, doch, das macht schon jemand und ich habe die Wette verloren, also ich musste dann 10 Dollar zahlen. Es kam dann ein Mädel namens Binks und hat gesagt, okay, sie würde das jetzt wirklich versuchen, so ein 21-jähriges Mädchen, irgendwo aus Albuquerque oder so, mit so einem Ero-Käsenschnitt, ganz nettes Mädchen, die hat dann übrigens für das nächste Monochrom eine dreiseitige, extrem coole feministische Berichterstattung von dieser Experience geschrieben. Weil sie hat zum Beispiel noch nie vor einem Dildo verwendet und solche Sachen halt. Und die lag dann tatsächlich auf diesem Tisch hinter diesem Leintuch und dann war dieser riesige Faxilla-Robot, der da halt mit der Kettensäge und mit dem Dildo da halt getan hat und so. Und sie ist zweimal gekommen und sie hat vier Meter hoch ejakuliert.
Ich werd nicht wieder als so eine großartige Dynamik.
Es muss eine lustige Veranstaltung gewesen sein. Es war sehr, sehr lustig. Es ist eben genau das, was wir bei Monochrom in Gern versuchen, dass man das nicht vollkommen ins Akademische abtriffen zu lassen, sondern immer auch so eine anständige Portion an Freaks dabei zu haben, an Sachen, die performativ sind, wo was weitergeht, die auch lustig sind, die auch entertainend sind, aber gleichzeitig halt nie das Ernsthafte und das Politische irgendwie aus dem Blickwinkel lassen. Das versuchen wir halt gerne.
Ja, 2007 habe ich gelesen, ist unter anderem auch noch das internationale Jahr des Politismus. Das habt ihr ausgerufen.
Das haben wir ausgerufen, und zwar geht es da darum, dass wir ein großes Problem mit monotheistischen Religionen auf dieser Welt haben. Offensichtlich. Also vor allem gerade diese drei Brüder-Religionen, eh klar, Brüder-Religionen, die sich da gegenseitig fertig machen, weil sie sich halt nicht darüber einig werden können, wer jetzt den wahren Gott hat und so weiter. Das ist immer ziemlich blöd. Und wir haben eben gesagt, Monotheismus ist Diktatur und Politismus ist Demokratie. Das heißt, wenn jeder, welchen Gott auch immer haben will oder jede Göttin, ist eh klar, dann ist das nicht so ein großes Problem. Und wir haben eben damit begonnen mit einer Aktion in einem Steinbruch, die hieß Free Barium Nitrate. Und barium Nitrate ist das brennende Zeug in Wunderkerzen. Dass man ja heute vielleicht beim Silvester Song auch noch verwenden wird.
Das knallt ja auch schon ganz ordentlich da draußen.
Naja, und wie gesagt, barium Nitrate und diese Wunderkerzen werden hauptsächlich in so monothechischem Kontext gebraucht. Also z.B. in Österreich hängt man die ja und in Deutschland auch an den Weihnachtsbaum. Oder in England z.B. werden die Wunderkerzen am 5. November verwendet, in der Guy Fawkes Night, also wo die Anglikaner feiern, dass sie diesen Pulveranschlag des Katholiken überstanden haben. Weil der Katholik namens Guy Fawkes wollte nämlich einen Anschlag verüben und der wurde vereitelt und deswegen feiern sich die Anglikaner immer damit selbst ab, dass sie die Katholiken dann doch besiegt haben. Remember the 5th of November. Und in den amerikanischen Gefilden ist es natürlich so, dass am 4. Juli das so gern verwendet wird, wenn sie ihre semi-sikulare Nation hochhalten und selbst feiern und so. Und wir haben uns gesagt, wir wollen das Bariumnitrat befreien, wir nehmen 10.000 Wunderkerzen, binden sie zusammen, zünden sie auf einmal an und wollen die Götter und Göttinnen aus dem Jenseits wieder zurückholen. Das haben wir auch gemacht, das war eine 6 Meter hohe Stichflamme. Wie viel? 10.000.
10.000 Wunderkerzen auf einmal. Eine 6 Meter hohe Stichflamme? Wo hat ihr das gemacht?
In einem Steinbruch. In der Entfernung waren die Zuseherinnen und Zuseher. Und wir hatten auch die lokale Feuerwehr aus Linderbrunn.
Hatte ihr eine Vorstellung davon, welches Ausmaß ein brandes Feuer haben würde? Also ihr habt euch schön weit fern gehalten.
Ich hatte so einen Feuerschutzanzug an. Und wenn ich den nicht angehabt hätte, ich wäre wahrscheinlich verkohlt.
Ihr habt ja auch Projekte, die zur Beteiligung einladen, wenn ich das richtig mitbekomme.
Politismus übrigens auch, wenn jemand da draußen Lust und Laune hat. Wir haben ja mehrere Aktionen zum Thema Politismus in diesem Jahr gemacht. Das war eben nur die erste. Und wir sammeln zum Beispiel Rezensionen von den Lieblingsgöttern und Göttinnen von Leuten. Also wenn ihr auf Englisch bitte schreibt uns doch eine E-Mail mit so einer, keine Ahnung, 2.000, 5.000 Zeichenbeschreibung eures Lieblingsgottes oder eurer Lieblingsgöttin, warum die so cool ist und es kommt dann bei uns auf den Politismus-Blog. Also wir haben jetzt quasi für das ganze Jahr, deswegen Jahr des Politismus, mehrere Veranstaltungen zum Thema eben gemacht. Und das werden wir jetzt auch noch fortführen bis zum 26. Jänner. Da ist das Jahr vorbei. Und bis dahin hoffentlich noch ein paar Sachen bekommen von euch.
Okay, was ihr aussammelt, sind Typos oder das Out...
Outsourcing betreiben wir sehr gerne, jaja. Also zum Beispiel diese Typogeschichte ist, dass wir, wir sammeln das in Deutsch und in Englisch. In Deutsch heißt es Ortus und in Englisch heißen es Toibs. Und zwar sammeln wir da im deutschen Raum, was wahrscheinlich relevanter ist für das deutsche Publikum jetzt, die schönsten Tippfehler einer angenommenen deutschen Sprach- und Wertegemeinschaft. Das heißt, wenn ihr einen schönen Tippfehler habt, mein E-Mail ist ja nur dazu erfunden worden, um schöne Tippfehler zu generieren, dann geht's doch auf monochromat-orto und schaut euch mal, was es da so gibt und schickt uns eure schönsten Tippfehler. Und wenn die wirklich gut sind, dann kommen sie auch in die Liste rein.
Grauen Zeitschrift.
Zum Beispiel, ja. Das war übrigens im Standard einer liberalen österreichischen Tageszeitung. KurziFix, sehr schön. Ich weiß es gar nicht auswendig, was sind denn deine Lieblinge?
Ja, ich schau gerade mal drauf, was irgendwie lustig ist.
Penisonsvorsorge, zum Beispiel finde ich auch sehr gut. Das ist natürlich ein Gassenhauer, aber es gibt so schöne, zum Beispiel auch...
Zweitweise.
Zweitweise. Snase, zum Beispiel finde ich es so, also Nase mit S vorne. Wie das passiert ist, keine Ahnung.
Oder der Zusammenhanf. Okay, ich sehe schon, hier ist einiges dabei. Also, falls ihr noch einen Verschreiber habt, dann ist Monochrom immer gerne empfänglich.
Wir haben viele solche Sachen.
Also es gibt hier ein Web-Formular, da kann man das einfach...
Wir sammeln ganz viele solche Sachen. Wir sammeln zum Beispiel auch schlechte Restaurant-Kunst.
Müssen das dann richtige Verschreiber sein, die man selber gemacht hat?
Wir können es ja nicht überprüfen.
Naja, aber jetzt mal so zu Motivation.
Zu Motivation würde ich sagen ja. Also, bescheißen ist Fahrt. Respekt, sag ich ja.
Ja, eure Webseite quillt ja über. Ich meine, alle fragen sich immer, wie ihr das eigentlich macht. Also jetzt auf dem Kongress gab es ja auch wieder zwei Präsentationen. Einerseits diese wunderschöne Pop-Kultur-Übersicht mit lustigen Pop-Songs, die alle... tragischen Pop-Songs, die alle irgendwie mit Computern oder der digitalen Welt zu tun haben. Wir hatten ja dann auf der Abschluss-Fan-Stage auch echt großen Spaß. Wie ist das noch? Surf Multimedia?
Surf Multimedia von den Eurocats aus dem Jahre 1996.
Oh, war ja...
also was für eine... Das war das Spannende daran irgendwie. Alle Leute... Also wir haben uns ja Mühe gegeben, da schön 17, 18 schöne Beispiele zusammenzufassen, wo natürlich Trashige auch dabei sein müssen, ist eh klar. Aber ist dann klar, dass natürlich der Hyper-Trash natürlich der ist, nachdem alle natürlich lechzen. Und dann kommen natürlich dann jeden Tag 20 Leute, die sagen, wo ist denn das, wo kann ich denn das Lied finden und deswegen haben wir uns ja dann entschlossen, dass dann der versammelten Menge dann bei der Abschlussveranstaltung am 24C3 noch mal hinzuknallen und es noch mal rocken zu lassen.
Ja, das blieb ja dann auch nicht, blieb sein Effekt nicht schuldig, aber es war super Stimmung am Start. Ja, also man könnte jetzt hier noch endlos durch die Projekte durchgehen, die ihr schon gemacht habt. Das ist alles irgendwie so ein Fröhn, das meine ich. Dieses Jahr war aber auch wirklich echt krass, ihr seid dann irgendwie noch als Zombie-Meute durch Wien gelaufen, ihr gründet eigene Verschwörungs-Logen oder was hat es mit dieser Lord-Jim-Lose auf sich?
Na das ist eine spannende Geschichte, im Jahre 1985 gab es drei Österreichische und einen deutschen Künstler, alle Männer, und zwar Jörg Schlicke und, na bloß zwei Deutsche, Albert Öhl und Martin Kippenberger, die auch sehr bekannt sind und Kippenberger ist einer der Superseller am deutschen Kunstmarkt, ist eh klar, dass er mittlerweile tot ist und dann gab es den Wolfgang Bauer, der eigentlich Literat ist und den Jörg Schlicke und die beiden aus Österreich und diese vier Künstler haben sie halt so, wie das halt so Künstlerart ist, so ein bisschen so angesoffen und haben darüber nachgedacht, verdammt, wir haben jetzt demnächst eine Gruppenausstellung gemeinsam hier in Graz, wir brauchen irgendein Thema, da ist eh klar, das alte Deadline-Problem halt irgendwie und im Suft dann halt haben sie halt eben beschlossen, wir gründen eine Künstlerloge, so wie eine Mafialoge, nur halt Das ist nur halt eine Künstlerloge und dann versuchen wir, möglichst viele Leute zu bewegen, bei dieser Künstlerloge teilzunehmen. Dann tun wir halt so, wie die Welt übernehmen und so. Irgendwie war halt diese Sufidee halt. Und da kippen wir dann halt auf so ein Bierdeckel ein Logo draufgemalt, nämlich Sonne-Busen-Hammer, ja. Und ja, das machen wir jetzt super klasse. Und so ist es halt entstanden. Und diese Loge haben sie eben Lord Jim Loge genannt, weil sie halt alle große Fans waren von diesem Lord Jim, nämlich dieser Romangestalt von Joseph Conrad, der eben auch Heart of Darkness geschrieben hat im 19. Jahrhundert. So ein Romancier war das eben damals. Und deswegen haben sie das eben Lord Jim Loge genannt und sie haben sich mehrere Ziele gesetzt. Erstens einmal jeder, der fragt, ob er in die Loge rein darf, wird nicht aufgenommen, es dürfen keine Frauen aufgenommen werden. Also es sind nur so Jovi-Ecke, die dann irgendwie anders Göttinnen sind, aber sie dürfen nicht in die Loge rein und so. Und sie wollen, dass das Logo, dieses Sonnebusen-Hammer-Logo, bekannter wird als das von Coca-Cola. Und das waren quasi ihre Zielsetzungen. Und das wollten sie dadurch erreichen, dass sie halt das Logo auf möglichst viele Kunstwerke draufgegeben haben. Also auf Selbstporträts von Kippenberger ist das dann oben, auf Skulpturen von Schlicke und in Büchern von Bauern, überall kommt das Logo.
So Virals-Marketing sozusagen.
Jaja, genau so. Und das haben sie dann einige Zeit auch so gemacht. Und es gab dann so einen Höhepunkt im Jahre 1997, wo der Martin Kippenberger, damals schon Superstar, zu Dokumenta eingeladen wurde. In Dokumenta ist halt eben die größte deutsche Kunstgeschichte, und wenn nicht glaube ich sogar weltweit top oder zweitgrößte Kunstausstellung. Und dort hat er dann so Fake-U-Bahneingänge gebaut, und auf denen war eben dieses Sonnenbusen-Hammer-Logo oben drauf. Dadurch war das natürlich noch viel mystischer, und was ist denn das, und überhaupt und sowieso. Allerdings ist dann mit der Zeit natürlich, Kippenberger ist dann im selben Jahr gestorben und so, und die Leute haben sich dann immer so drum gekümmert, nur mehr der Jörg Schlicke in Graz eigentlich hat sich um das gekümmert. Und Jörg Schlicke hat ein paar Jahre später dann, bevor wir sie überhaupt kennengelernt haben, Daniel, Fabel und Annika Kronberger kennengelernt, die mittlerweile Teil von Monochrom sind, aber die damals eben auf der FH-Jurneeum in Graz studiert haben, und er war ihr Professor und hat sie dann eben dort kennengelernt und hat dann ein bisschen so verfolgt, was die so machen. Und die wurden dann später so ein Teil von Monochrom und er hat sich dann ein bisschen dafür interessiert, aha, was ist ein Monochrom, was machen die so? Und hat uns eines Tages im Jahre 2005 dann quasi zum Ganselsuppenessen eingeladen, also sagen so eine Gansessuppe, und hat uns da eine ganz tragische Geschichte erzählt, nämlich dass er selbst quasi im finalen Stadium krebskrank ist und dass er demnächst sterben wird, aber er will die Lord-Jim-Loge nicht untergehen lassen. Er will die quasi jemanden vermachen oder weitergeben, dass mit dem was weiter getan wird, weil das eben so schön wäre und man muss dann noch was damit machen. Und wir haben gesagt, ai, jessus, na, das ist ja eine totale Ehre, dass wir Monochroms das jetzt kriegen. Aber was machen wir denn damit, mit dieser Loge da jetzt? Und er hat noch dazu gesagt, wir müssen uns ordentlich rocken lassen. Uns mit dem ordentlich rocken lassen, wie ist denn das möglich? Mit dieser so Hype-Show-Loge irgendwie und da hat er die Vorgeschichte schon mal 20 Minuten zu erzählen, worum es geht. Also was machen wir denn mit dem Teil? Und wir haben ihm dann vorgeschlagen, dass wir als junge neoliberale, profitorientierte Künstlerinnengruppe das Ding einfach in einem Hostile-Takeover übernehmen und dann Franchises machen und da so Start-ups machen damit und prinzipiell überhaupt brachliegende Künstlergruppen kaufen und teuer verkaufen wollen, also quasi als Idee. So wie das halt so passiert mit so Sanierungsfirmen und so. Und er hat gesagt, ja, großartige Idee, da mach ich mit und so, das ist perfekt und so. Da tun wir so, als ob ihr mir das quasi abkauft oder ich verkaufe euch das quasi für so ein Euro oder so oder sagen wir halt für 2.000 Euro und dann macht ihr so Pressekonferenzen und so Sachen und das ist cool, ja. Und wir haben das dann wirklich gemacht. Er hat es aber leider nicht mehr erlebt, weil er ist dann im Dezember 2005 eben gestorben. Und wir haben das dann eben fortgeführt und haben eben quasi folgendes getan. Wir haben einfach so eine Künstlermarke hoch im symbolischen Kapital, natürlich, weil der Kippenberger dabei war und Wolfgang Bauer und Schlick und weiß Gott war es, aber niedrig im realen Kapital quasi sagen verwendet und um da das Start-up damit zu machen und haben da so eine Pressekonferenz organisiert und eine Presseaussendung gemacht und da stand im Wesentlichen drinnen, jetzt ist Monochrom der neue Besitzer, die neue besitzende Entität der Lord Jim Loge und wir haben natürlich dadurch, dass wir sie jetzt besitzen, dass sie uns verkauft wurde, alle Marken- und Nutzungsrechte und wenn wir alle Markenrechte haben, haben wir natürlich auch alle Markenrechte am Logo und wir haben natürlich die Markenrechte daran, dass dieses Logo auf diesen ganzen Bildern oben ist und diesen Büchern drin ist und auf diesen Installationen oben drauf ist und wir wollen verdammt nochmal unsere 15% von dem ganzen Scheiß natürlich haben. Ist natürlich juristisch überhaupt nicht haltbar in keiner Weise, aber wir haben das quasi proklamiert und haben damit gerechnet, das war es jetzt halt einmal.
Affirmativer Turbokapitalismus.
Genau so ist es ja und haben auch damit gerechnet, dass da große Reaktionen kommen, aber tatsächlich haben wir diesen Brief dann rausgeschickt an alle Großen, an das MoMA in New York und an das MoMA dort, also an alle möglichen Galerien und Museen und haben dann gewartet und tatsächlich kamen dann Anrufe und E-Mails, wo dann drin stand, ja und so und können wir uns irgendwie außergerichtlich einigen und wir haben das gar nicht gepackt und so und wir hatten überhaupt keine rechtliche Grundlage, also wenn wir das dann tatsächlich gemacht hätten, wären wir wahrscheinlich, also echt quasi, weil das Absurde, das Absurde wird mittlerweile einfach schon für bare Münze genommen, also man kann gar nicht absurd genug rüberkommen. Wir haben uns so gewundert darüber, dass scheinbar große Museen keine guten Rechtsberater haben, also die haben keine guten Leute in ihrer, weil das ist vollkommen bizarr, also wenn jemand ein Coca-Cola-Logo malt, ist es eine künstlerische Interpretation dessen, da kann man keine Markenrechte dran geltend machen. Und wir haben dann aber trotz all dem, die ist ungefähr zwei Monate ein bisschen in Panik gehalten und so hingehalten und immer, und he, und Briefwechsel und so und so und so. Und dann ist es dann sozusagen ausgelaufen, weil wir haben dann natürlich keinen Geräuschen davon bekommen, aber haben uns dann gedacht, na gut, wir müssen ja irgendwas damit jetzt machen und haben dann rausgefunden, dass Coca-Cola Österreich einen Preis ausgeschrieben hat, nämlich den Coca-Cola Light Art Award. Und dieser Coca-Cola Light Art Award ging es darum, dass Künstler was einschicken sollten. Und die Jury würde dann darüber bestimmen, ob das ein gutes Werk ist. Und wenn das eingeschickte Werk gut ist, dann würde es auf 50 oder 100.000 Coca-Cola Light Flaschen als Sleeve drauf gedruckt werden, also dass die Flasche draußen einen Umschlag hat. Und dieser Umschlag ist dann das Kunstwerk. Da haben wir uns gedacht, na, da machen wir mit. Erstens einmal, die wollten ja sowieso, dass sie bekannter werden als Coca-Cola.
Ja, das wäre ja im Prinzip der Siegesszug der Lord Jim Logo.
Genau, das haben wir dann gemacht. Und der Daniel hat dann halt so ein Blatt Papier genommen und diesen Stempel, diesen Lord Jim Logo, ein Stempel, das war quasi das symbolische Ding mit dieser Übergabe, hat dann das halt so in fünf Minuten so drauf gestempelt. Wir haben das hingeschickt und wir haben gewonnen.
Nein, oder? Was wirklich auf der Coca-Cola-Flasche?
Ja.
Auf wie vielen?
100.000 oder so. Und wir haben noch 5.000 Euro Kohle gekriegt. Und das ist eine gute Performance, würde ich mal sagen. Auf jeden Fall. Nach einem halben Jahr nach der Übernahme.
Das ist Hacking.
Ja, das ist Hacking.
Und ich meine, Real-Life-Hacking, es gilt so als Anerkennung, Hacking, wir haben natürlich unsere Computer-Security, wir haben die Programmierung und das und jenes.
Wir haben das Logpicking.
Das Social Hacking. Und das Social Hacking, das zählt dazu. Ich würde fast noch eine neue Kategorie aufmachen, dass man auch wirklich dieses Real-Life-Hacking nicht so sehr im Sinne von ich möchte jetzt eine Information kriegen, die mir nicht gewährt werden soll, sondern einfach die Leute einfach mal nur auf eine falsche Spur zu bringen, um ihren Realitätswahrnehmung umzudrehen. Einfach sie einfach mal in ihrer Tumben-Wahrnehmung des normalen, in Anführungsstrichen, einfach zu erwischen, durchzuschütteln, sodass sie einfach, wenn auch nur für einen kurzen Moment, einfach gar nicht mehr so richtig wissen, was jetzt eigentlich geht.
Ich glaube, das ist das, was mein Freund mit dem Context-Hacking meint, das ist ein bisschen spezifisch halt. Die Schlussgeschichte dann noch im Sitz noch kurz.
Das ist wahrer Diskordianismus, wenn ich das im Übrigen noch mal hinweille.
Ich danke vielmals.
Also ich meine, Diskordia alleine, das müssen wir auseinanderhalten.
Und dann war es eben so, wir haben 5000 Euro gemacht, da waren wir angestarkt, jetzt können wir noch mehr machen. Und wir wollten einerseits natürlich die Geschichte erzählen, weil genau das, was ich dir jetzt erzählt habe, in irgendeiner anderen Form, quasi als einfach wieder mal niederschreiben, quasi diese Geschichte weiterbringen oder vermitteln. Und gleichzeitig natürlich Kohle damit machen, weil das war irgendwie diese Überaffirmationsidee natürlich. Und deswegen haben wir uns gedacht, ja, wir machen einen Gemäldezyklus, einen zwölfteiligen Öl-Gemäldezyklus, so richtige Öl-Schinken so große, wo die Geschichte der Gründung der Lord-Jim-Loge bis zu unserer Übernahme und so weiter und alles erzählt wird, was wir natürlich gleichzeitig auch verkaufen können, weil natürlich quasi sowas verkauft sich halt immer, wenn man schön an die Wohnzimmerwand hängen kann. Und um das quasi wirklich zu machen, um auch einen Profit dabei zu haben, haben wir diese zwölf Bilder im Photoshop gemacht, nach Kindergeschichte und in China malen lassen. In 140 cm Höhe, 100 cm Breite, so riesige Öl-Schinken in drei Wochen. Und haben dafür 2500 Euro gezahlt, diesem chinesischen Malernahmensgut in Kankan, in der chinesischen Provinz. Und haben es pro Stück um 4500 Euro weiterverkauft. Und so funktioniert der Weltmarkt. Ist ja klar, ja. Und wir haben, dadurch, es gibt auch das Vorleitz, der Bild des Zyklus ist, wo der chinesische Maler vor seinem Malstudio sich selbst dann gemalt hat, quasi mit dem großen Corbis-Logo oben drüber, mit so einem Corbis-Watermark. Und das ging's natürlich. Und weil wir natürlich alle gut Menschen sind, haben wir dann auch gesagt, ok, du kriegst natürlich auch von unseren Verkaufserlösen, von diesen 4500 Euro pro Stück, kriegst du natürlich einen fetten Anteil davon und so, weil davon kannst du wahrscheinlich Jahrzehnte leben und genau um das geht's ja quasi. Und China ist natürlich ein großer Kopiermarkt, von Prada-Handtaschen über DVDs bis Harry Potter, es gibt 27 Harry Potter-Bücher in China.
Ach, die haben mehr als die anderen?
Die haben mehr, die haben neu geschrieben, ganz einfach. Und natürlich auch Kunstkopiermarkt. Also da gibt's einerseits so Leute wie Gun-Kan-Kan, der ist fast so was wie ein Meister, der hat halt so ein kleines Geschäft und da hat er halt zwei, drei Angestellte und da kriegt er halt eine Anfrage, irgendwas zu malen, ein Foto oder irgend so was und dann wird das halt dort gemacht und wird nach Europa oder wird irgendwo hingeschickt halt. Und dann gibt's natürlich die andere Variante, diese richtige Fließbandmalerei, wo dann keine Ahnung, 20 Leute nebeneinander sitzen, einer mit dem roten Pinsel, einer mit dem grünen Pinsel, einer mit dem gelben Pinsel, einer mit dem schwarzen Pinsel und dann fahren halt so die Leinwände vorbei und dann macht jeder halt so einen Punkt drauf und am Schluss kommen halt jeden Tag 15.000 Van Goghs Sonnenbücher raus.
Oha, könnte man sich eigentlich auch nochmal eine komplette neue Edition von Hitlers Tagebüchern 1945 bis 1986 machen?
Wahrscheinlich mit besserer Qualität als bei Kujao. Und da gibt es nämlich auch einen Markt, also wenn man halt irgendwo in so Einkaufszentren geht oder zum Ikea oder so, wo es halt Gemälde gibt, die sind alle in China hergestellt und da gibt es einen gigantischen Kopiermarkt für Kunst. Und das ist ja auch das Spannende daran und da trifft sich ja auch wieder Kunst und Hackertum natürlich, weil die Diskussionen über Creative Commons, Diskussionen über Kopien und so weiter, wird ja groß geführt, aber oftmals wird das Physikalische kopieren und wird ja oft nicht wirklich bedacht und das ist natürlich gerade jetzt auch in einer politischen Dimension extrem wichtig, weil die Weltwirtschaft läuft deswegen, weil drüben zu extremen Billigpreisen extrem qualitative Arbeit geleistet wird von diesen Menschen. Auf das wollte man natürlich auch hinweisen halt.
Ja Mensch, Johannes, jetzt können wir wahrscheinlich noch ein paar Stunden drauflegen. Machen wir aber jetzt mal nicht.
Machen wir nicht.
Machen wir nicht. Aber wir treffen uns sicherlich nochmal, um die weiteren Aspekte zu besprechen. Das wird nicht das letzte Mal gewesen sein, aber ein schöner Einstieg in das Projekt Monochrom, was uns allen sehr im Herzen liegt. Und ja, wie geht's weiter? Du fährst wieder nach Hause nach Wien.
Ich fliege morgen nach Wien zurück und wir haben jetzt hoffentlich noch eine Orgier da irgendwie oder so.
Das denke ich auch, ja. Das auf jeden Fall.
Und ihr da draußen auch, schaltet das aus und habt eine Orgier.
Genau, habt Orgien. Ja, das ist ein schönes Schlusswort. Habt Orgien, viele Grüße von Chaosradio Express und viel Spaß dabei. Das war Ausgabe Nummer 62, Johannes, vielen Dank.
So eine schöne Nummer.
Ja, ist es?
64 wäre schon viel schöner, aber 62 ist auch schön.
Achso, ich hätte es jetzt auch noch rausschieben können.
Nein.
Jetzt ist vorbei, jetzt haben wir es gesagt. 62. Und dann können wir uns ja für die nächste eine schöne Zahl aussuchen. Da gibt es ja noch mehr schöne Zahlen. Habt ihr schon mal was über Numerologie gemacht?
Ich glaube, es gab mal in einem Monochrom einen Artikel über Numerologie. In einem dieser vielen hundertseitigen Publikationen.
Okay, vielleicht fällt uns ja zu dem Thema noch was ein. Okay, das war's, Chaosradio Express, ich sage tschüss, bis bald, tschüss.